Hey youtubers it's Charlie and I had a chance
to go see the Guardians of The Galaxy IMAX
footage.
So this video is going to be a review of that.
When I get to spoilers I'll just say spoiler
warning.
But it was basically 17 minutes of the movie,
the full movie is a little over 2 hours long.
Hello new people, if you're just finding me
for the first time I do weekly Marvel videos,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I have a bunch of links in the description
and at the end of the video in case you want
to travel down the youtube Marvel rabbit hole.
Most of the footage expanded on things we've
already seen in the trailers.
Like the lineup, it adds a lot more context
for other characters like Karen Gillan's Nebula,
Ronan, Gamora.
All of the footage of them in the Guardians
prison seems like it's intended to explain
who all these characters are in a really concise
way.
Especially if you haven't read the comics.
I know a lot of you ask whether or not you
need to read anything before you see the movie,
but you don't.
The movie takes care of all that in really
funny quick ways.
It doesn't waste time that could be used to
move the story forward.
The Guardian characters narrate a lot of each
other's backstories as like they're funny
anecdotes.
But the movie works so well I feel like it
doesn't need to explain anything.
Even if you don't know anything about the
comics you will love this movie.
Even way back when they screened that first
comic con teaser of the lineup set to Hooked
on a Feeling, everyone had the sense that
this would be the kind of superhero adventure
movie that would change what you think a superhero
movie is allowed to do.
It makes me very very hopeful for what even
weirder movies like Doctor Strange are going
to look like when they get here.
Bottom Line, you have to go see this movie
in IMAX, you don't have to see it in 3D, but
you should definitely see it in IMAX.
Personally I'm not a huge fan of 3D, I feel
like it hurts most movies.
So let's talk about spoilers.
Careful in case you don't want to know anything,
because I'm just going to go beat for beat
what we actually saw in the footage.
Here we go, We open on the John C. Reilly
dialogue, when they're getting processed.
But it opens up showing us bits from different
characters like Ronan kneeling at Thanos'
Rocket Throne from Avengers.
The rocket throne shows up in almost every
comic Thanos appears in, it's one of his most
iconic set pieces.
We start getting everyone's backstories, Gamora
who was basically adopted by Thanos and turned
into a killing machine.
We learn a little about her motivation too.
She lets us know that what she came from is
far worse than the threat of Ronan's Accuser
Corps so that's part of the reason she's so
gung ho about going apeshit on the Kree.
They're not half as bad as life with Thanos.
Thanos wasn't actually
in the footage.
We learn just how attached Peter Quill is
to his artifacts from Earth, he's the son
of a human woman and the Spartoi Emperor.
He's a prince who just hates his father.
He has spent most of his adult life in space
traveling as part of Yondu's crew of theives.
Michael Rooker's Yondu is essentially a pirate
in this movie.
So you can understand why they cast Michael
Rooker.
There is a bit of 'shipping between Quill
and Gamora, but if you've read the comics,
she's like a force of nature.
She doesn't really have relationships the
way normal people would, so they're not a
couple or anything.
Rocket Racoon explains Drax saying he's from
a super literate race, so he'll understand
any reference you throw at him.
It comes off as funny just because look at
him.
I started picturing him with a pair of reading
glasses.
We get a shot of Rocket getting hosed down
and you see all the cybernetic implants in
his body.
It's really horrific, he was a normal raccoon
that was experimented on.
That's how he gained bipedal motion, heightened
intelligence and the power to speak.
Groot mostly comes off as the gentle giant
you see in the trailers.
But when then they get walked into gen pop
and all the other prisoners start going nuts
and someone tries to beat the crap out of
Quill until Rocket and Groot go crazy on him
and declare he's under their protection.
That's from that scene in the trailer with
them spinning around screaming.
Then they plan a prison break that Groot messes
up because he doesn't want anyone to get hurt.
Which starts this epic action set piece where
they all actually escape from the prison.
It felt a lot like that scene in Winter Soldier
where Captain America jumped on the ship in
the beginning and took down everyone on the
boat without stopping to take a breath.
It's almost like one continuous action scene.
Very intense, very cool.
Then we see some footage of Rocket doing some
computer hacking that reminded me of that
scene when Tony Stark and Bruce Banner were
being science nerds in the staff room.
I feel like Rocket could show Tony Stark a
good time.
We got to see Ronan kneeling at Thanos' Rocket
throne.
No Thanos, but still awesome.
And we saw a full on shot of Michael Rooker.
He looks like this.
Ronan's Dark Aster, this giant ship was awesome.
We saw Rocket is flying his Warbird around
Knowhere destroying Ronan's Necrocraft ships.
A lot of the big battle scenes.
That was pretty much it, the footage didn't
seem that long but I'm so much more excited
for the movie now.
Marvel is like a crack dealer just standing
on the corner handing out free footage.
You definitely get the sense that Marvel is
building to a Thanos-Centric movie but it's
still a long ways off.
I can't wait to hear Josh Brolin's Thanos
voice.
There have already been rumors about the sequel
and characters it might bring in from other
Marvel teams, but this being the first big
super weird Marvel story is going to go down
as a watershed moment for big budget weirdness.
This really is the test for phase 3 next year.
Can Marvel spend a hundred and fifty million
dollars on weirdness of this level.
I'm a big fan of the comics, so of course
I say yes, but I feel like the movie is so
non-geek friendly it's totally something you
could take your Mom to and she would also
enjoy it.
The actual movie won't be out till August
1st, so Guardians won't be going to Comic
Con, they'll be promoting their other upcoming
movies there like Avengers 2, Ant-Man and
probably confirming which other films will
be part of phase 3.
of the Five they've announced, only two are
still unconfirmed.
There's Captain America 3, Thor 3 and Avengers
3.
I think those other two will be Doctor Strange
and Black Widow.
Definitely Doctor Strange, but the other option
instead of Black Widow would be Guardians
2.
They haven't set a date for the Guardians
Sequel yet.
And typically Marvel does a new sequel for
each character or team movie every two to
three years.
So I'm hoping we don't have to wait till phase
4 to see a second Guardians movie.
So if you had a chance to see the IMAX footage
let me know what your favorite part was and
if you didn't see it, let me know what you're
hoping to see.
My next bonus video will post next week, be
sure to subscribe to get it.
Check the description for extra Marvel links
and click here for my Ronan the Accuser video
and click here to learn about Brandon Routh
becoming the new Atom on Arrow season 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!